Nicola jokic spectacular once again
he had a triple double in game one 41
points in game two and a 30-20 triple
double in game three he's with Lisa
Nicola you guys pulled away in the third
quarter but coach has been on you guys
about the fourth quarters of these games
what was different about this fourth
quarter I mean uh we were just I think
more more log clean more Focus you know
at the end we had a little a little
miscommunication but I think in a global
communication is uh was on the high
point today and I think that's why we
won the game you are the first person in
NBA history to have a 30 20 10 NBA
Finals game what does that mean to you I
mean to be honest not not much uh I
figured you were going to say that but
uh yes I'm just glad that we won a game
it was a big one for us just because
they won in our Arena so we just didn't
want to go down to one Jamal really got
you guys going early what did you
appreciate about his game tonight he's
playing the whole the whole playoffs
he's playing phenomenal if you get going
guys he's shooting the ball really well
he's a really good leader out there and
we're just following him and Christian
Brown his impact yes I told I always
talk about him as a champion as a winner
he's over making a winning plays uh
whatever whatever he's doing he's doing
aggressive and uh I think he has the
future in this league
you've got the momentum back how do you
keep it now Nicola yes I mean we gotta
win the next one that's that's our
mindset and uh just win the next one and
uh that's how we're gonna get to the
goal thanks
all right Lisa and look at those two
first 30-point triple doubles each in
NBA history and that's not just the
playoffs that's not just the finals
that's ever and they do it after that
disappointing game two loss at home
where their coach questioned their
effort he will be praising their effort
I I love what I'm seeing Monte Morris
who used to be a teammate last year he's
out there greeting I mean it's the way
he's
I mean he's just such a giver
just how he conducted his interview you
can understand why they have the
environment that they have and his
answers they're believable